so this video is absolutely spectacular
this happened a couple days ago if you
did not see it it's just so wonderful so
you guys know what's going on the biden
administration basically is not taking
care of the border as chuck said about 2
million people are going to run through
this year then what happens in texas and
in florida because we have sane
functioning governors our governors are
now bussing illegal immigrants to
washington dc which is a wonderful plan
they don't have to stay here and if we
don't want them here that is the policy
of these states unfortunately we have
states rights and we're going to send
them to dc now dc muriel bowser is the
mayor of dc and they've got a whole
bunch of council people over there who
want it to be a sanctuary city and
nobody's illegal it's all of the stuff
that sounds sort of right but then in a
functional way does not work so we
covered it i think a week or two ago
that in dc all of their homeless
shelters are now being filled up with
illegals so this video came out this is
dc councilwoman brienne nadew and she is
very upset because now dc is being
overrun by the by the very people that
she wanted to come into the country as
long as they were going to stay in texas
so it's been said but it's worth
reiterating that the governors of texas
and arizona have created this crisis
and the federal government has not
stepped up to assist the district of
columbia so we um along with our
regional partners will do what we've
always done we'll rise to the occasion
we've learned from border towns
like el paso and brownsville
and in many ways
the governors of texas and arizona
have turned us into a border town we
don't know how long this will take
to resolve we don't know how long they
will continue busing and so the right
thing to do here is to be prepared to
ensure we can greet every bus we can get
people off on the right foot we can get
them where they want to go and that will
ultimately help them
in their
i mean liberal logic it basically makes
people stupid
this woman okay so first off she's
saying it's it's the governors of texas
and arizona that are doing this now of
course as you know but she's somewhat
dim
the federal government is in charge of
our borders so she may not be happy that
the governors of texas and arizona and
florida are bussing people to d.c but
it's not their fault in the first place
the fault lies with the people that are
in charge of the border that's her party
right that's old joe and confused kamala
so that's number one then she says
something that really shows you what
these people are now she's very upset
and why is she upset because dc is
becoming a border town
but what do you mean a border town would
be full of immigrants and you'd think it
would be very
diverse very pluralistic and everybody
would be having a great time and there'd
be no crime what's the matter with
border towns or is for some reason she's
okay with border towns as long as
they're in texas and arizona but not in
dc and then at the end of course she
says but we'll do what we do which is
rise to the uh rise to it and we will
get to it and we're going to take care
of these people we will rise to the
moment and what she means by that is we
are going to take more tax money from
legal people and we are going to fund it
into programs that will do absolutely
nothing keep a certain set of people
here illegally we're going to keep them
in the welfare state it's going to
increase crime blah blah blah anyway i
say have out of dc enjoy
you